Eldon Rings Glenstone Sorcerers draw
power from the cosmos and its clintstone
but there is one type of sorcery that
the academy despises more than any other
Thorn sorceries these sorceries were
accidentally discovered by criminals
Exiles who will likely sent to the north
wearing crowns of thorns which bloodied
and blinded them as punishment for their
crimes but what no one knew at the time
is that red glintstone can be created
from the blood of sacrifices and so with
eyes bloodied the Exiles discovered
something called The Blood star in their
Eternal Darkness becoming the thorn
sorceress so why does the academy hate
their Thorn sorceries well Thorn
sorceries don't just rely upon
intelligence they also rely upon one's
Faith so that means that there's
something alive up there in the darkness
of the cosmos that can be understood
with intelligence yes but that responds
to one's Faith as well a bloody star
that favors the Sinners and their
sacrifice
thank you